we are pretty deep into november and
living in new york this time of year
always makes me feel the same way you
look outside and you see everyone
getting ready for the holiday season you
watch the leaves change color and grab a
hot cocoa you get home from a long day's
work and you sit on your couch
and you get a special sensation
you feel tingly all over
your whole body starts to shake
and you send a special text message to
your landlord
[Music]
turn on my heat baby
[Applause]
cause i'm feeling froze from my head
down to my toaster and
[Music]
how much money could this possibly save
how am i colder than mares who live in a
cave they're all sold out of heaters at
all the stores
this feels like camping i wake up shop
that i'm endorsed
i can see my breath and i hate it
i'm too cold to be this frustrated
and there's temperature i don't know how
long i'm gonna last if i knew where you
live i would whoop
[Music]
from my head down to my toaster and on
my meat baby
how can a place be this small but oh so
cold
[Music]
i didn't know it could be this cold
inside i'm impressed i may be under the
covers but i'm also fully dressed this
is not how americans should be living
imma have to wish people are happy for
the thanksgiving wait shut up shut up
is that the sound of the radiator
no it's just an angry cat in the back
alley god damn it
i got a frozen nose frosty toes i feel
like i'm gonna die icicles in my hair
but you don't care and it makes me wanna
cry you got me feeling numb and kinda
dumb cause i follow this every year it
makes me wanna fight really cold at
night it'd be warm if you lived here
but you would never live here
[Music]
there's that is that the radiator
no
nope neighbor just dropped their keys
god
damn
cheap ass landlord
turn on my heat baby
[Music]
cause i'm feeling froze from my head
down to my toes turned on my feet baby
shut up
now that that's the radiator coming on
right
i think it is
okay
finally
god it's good and toasty it's a little
too toasty
now it's too hot in here
i'm on fire baby
turn down my heat baby
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you